Alright guys, so now we're going to learn the reactionary order block trading strategy. So this is actually auto floor trading strategy but with more confirmation. And I do not mean confirming it on a smaller time for my thing. You will be confirming it on the same time for him. It's different than what you have seen on YouTube or on any other course.
Let's say we are in a downtrend that we have this change of character or market structure shift whatever you want to call it
Okay, once you have that you will have
Fairvalue gap plus auto block at this level now
Normally you would take your entry directly from here, right?
But in this scenario, what is a reactionary auto block?
So when price comes into this auto block, it must make a push up something like this that will create another imbalance and auto block.
Okay, it must create imbalance and auto block after mitigating the auto block and
farewell gap around this level. Once that happens, that is your confirmation entry.
It is gonna increase your win rate. This is what's all about. Okay, very simple
guys, I will repeat this again. So we have a market structure shift here. We got the
farewell gap on our blog in the discounted zone. Price comes back into the zone. Not
only you would buy it straight away, but sometimes it can just push through it. You want
to avoid losses. So you wait for price to give you another reaction. Right? Once price hits
this level it must create an impulsive move it does not need to break any
structure or anything it just needs to create an imbalance and auto block
that is it once you have that you can take your entry from that auto block now
you can either put your straw plus just below this new impulsive just below
this new low data is formed or you can put it down there just to be on the
safe side okay and voila that is it same for a continuation pattern
let's say we are in an uptrend price and makes another higher high right and
we got this fair value gap around here and auto block so this would have been an
and ABC pattern as well.
So what happens?
Price comes into this level, goes up, creates farewell gap.
And then you target the high.
That is it, guys.
So price broke, did a market structure break.
It created farewell gap in imbalance.
price made in impulsive move once the price hit the auto block and farewell gap at this level
It created farewell to gap on a block here as well. Now this is your confirmation entry
You don't want to go to the smaller timeframes and all that bullshit, okay?
You just can easily take your entry here and do not chase big risk reward guys
All right if you stick with
1 to 3 1 to 2 1 to 4 1 to 5
Trust me that is more than enough. Never choose a lot. Okay, never choose big risk reward ratios.
The price is gonna come to you, alright?
The market is not yours. It can reverse any time.
So why not just take your profits and enjoy the rest of the day?
But rather than holding the trade and expecting to hit like, I don't know, maybe 10 risk reward.
Yeah, sometimes you can hit it, but it's just not worth it guys.
So just take the profits and enjoy.
So I'll give you an example of this trading of this reaction on your autoblog.
So yeah.